this is the moment of the Stampede in
Sana hundreds of people had gathered at
a school to receive donations from a
wealthy businessman
as the crowd surged chaos ensured and
many were trapped in a narrow alley
the hospital has received 73 people
among them are those who are in critical
condition there are two patients in
intensive care and 13 other cases are in
need of surgeries
local authorities blame poor planning
the houthis who control Northern Yemen
including the capital say they've
arrested two local businessmen whom the
accused of failing to coordinate with
the police
we want to investigate the unfortunate
events and find a solution to make sure
it never happens again this is a great
tragedy many of our citizens died
at the end of Ramadan poor people often
gather outside the houses or businesses
of wealthy people hoping to receive
money during the holy month Muslims are
not only required to fast but also to
repent and show compassion for those
less fortunate Witnesses blame Security
Forces for opening fire to disperse the
crown which they say caused panic
what happened was a big tragedy and the
houthi leadership is keeping a close eye
on the situation besides by years of
violence and instability Yemen is one of
the poorest countries the United Nations
describes it as the world's worst
humanitarian crisis the Stampede
happened just days after the houthis and
Saudi officials discussed a truce to end
the war and reopen airports al-jazeera